Look at this display.
>> Tens of thousands [music] of people
gathered along the beach line to witness
2,300 drones and fireworks.
The show's biggest technical highlight
was a lifelike phoenix with wings of
fire created by over 2300 drones,
including 1,000 state-of-the-art pyro
drones igniting midair. A symbol of
renew, optimism, and rebirth. The
Phoenix mirrors Razar Kmer's own journey
of transformation and its ambition to
reimagine the future.
Guinness World Records has officially
certified as the world's largest aeropix
display formed by Jones. The the main
thing in the phoenix bird uh he he
reborn from his ash. That mean uh the
new uh beginning uh that we learn from
our uh from last uh life and start the
new life, the new start to to rise.
Another striking formation called the
welcome depicts a human person rising
from the sea with open arms symbolizing
the Emirates's warmth, openness and
hospitality.
As you could see, it was a very hypnotic
display. I mean, it was very appealing,
attractive. It looked awesome, right? A
bunch of drones flying in sync to make
this threedimensional thing happening
right before your eyes. But what was
going on? They said it, not me. a
phoenix rising from the ashes. The
phoenix rising from the ashes which
represents new beginnings, new life, all
this stuff. So, a lot of people could
blow that off and say, you know, this is
just about a new year, new year, new me.
Uh I'm like that phoenix from the ashes.
You know, I had a a bad last year, but I
it's going to be a new change, right?
That's a surface level type examination
of what's going on here. This was a
phoenix that literally morphed into this
AI humanoid robot thing. Now, it said it
was, you know, just uh some human man
with arms wide open welcoming people,
but the man is literally made up of AI
drones. So, Phoenix turns into AI man.
What does that mean? What does that mean
for 2026? What are they announcing? We
know that all these ceremonies, the
literally the word ceremony is a
religious ritual and we call these
things ceremony. Did you watch the the
halftime ceremony? You know, we are
saying these things openly without even
thinking what they mean.
All right. So, you see the phoenix and
he morphs. I didn't actually get the
morphing on here, but he morphs into the
man, the AI man.
What are they trying to tell us? All
right, check this out. What is the
occult meaning behind the phoenix rising
from the ashes? In occult traditions,
the phoenix rising from the ashes
symbolizes profound spiritual
transformation. Now, this isn't just,
oh, it's a new year, right? Spiritual
transformation, purification through
fire. Think you know the Bible when it
says uh it's witchcraft to put your
children through the fire and it says
overcoming destruction to achieve a
higher state. Overcoming destruction to
achieve a higher state and cyclical
rebirth mirroring the alchemical
process. All right. Alchemy is what this
has to do with of the old self dying to
be reborn as a perfected enlightened
soul representing hope, resilience, and
inner alchemy. Are you listening to the
language? This is not just, oh, this is
new year, new me. This is alchemy. All
right. Phoenix rising from the ashes.
It's the same as the oraoris, the snake
eating its tail. It's about death,
rebirth, and immortality.
But not immortality through Christ Jesus
who is the only way to the father, the
only one who can give us the gift of
everlasting life. This is immortality
through the occult, through science,
through uh witchcraft and science
together, which is literally the
definition of alchemy
is putting science and and sorcery
together. All right? And you can see
right here core occult meanings. It says
alchemy. The phoenix embodies the
alchemical great work. It says spiritual
death and rebirth, immortality and
transcendence.
Think about think biblically.
Transcendence. What does that mean? In
the garden of Eden, the serpent told
Eve, "Eat this fruit, your eyes will be
open. You'll become as God and you will
not surely die." Immortality, right? God
is immortal. If you eat this fruit, your
eyes will be open. This lie started in
the Garden of Eden and it's now it's
repackaged as the new age or alchemy or
whatever. Satan just has a new way of
repackaging the same thing over and
over. Now we got transhumanism. It's the
same thing. Check this out. This year we
actually discovered alchemy. I don't
think that's a coincidence. Look, this
is May 8th on the CERN website. It says
Alice detects the conversion of lead
into gold. Then on ABC News, all these
are from May 2025. We just This just
happened. Scientists turned lead into
gold for the first time, but only for a
split second. And look where it says um
that they achieved an ancient alchemist
dream. Then the next one says medieval
alchemists were right. And then then the
next one on ZME Science says this
startup claims it can turn uh mercury
into gold using fusion. And then it says
the age-old alchemist dream. So we
literally this year have achieved the
alchemist dream of turning lead into
gold. What has Trump been saying all
this year? What's Trump been saying?
We're entering into the golden age. The
golden age of enlightenment. The age of
Aquarius. The age of alchemy. That's
where we are entering. This is what this
whole phoenix rising from the ashes.
This is what all this was about
right here. I asked, "Did Alice Bailey
ever mention the concept of the phoenix
rising from the ashes?" And Google's
answer said yes. Alice Bailey's
writings, specifically materials
published by the Lucius Trust used the
phoenix rising from the ashes as a
symbol of humanity's periodic renewal
and spiritual transformation. So it goes
into this whole thing about civilization
cycles and spiritual transformation and
resilience of and strength and
purification and rebirth and
resurrection and spiritual evolution.
The phoenix rising from the ashes
represents the soul's journey through
trials to a higher more conscious state
of being. Now, this stuff might sound to
you innocent like, "Yeah, as a
Christian, I want to reach a, you know,
a deeper walk in my spiritual life this
year." This is not what this is talking
about. This goes back to the Garden of
Eden. This is reaching Christ
consciousness, which again might sound
okay to a Christian who doesn't
understand what Christ consciousness is.
This is the new age. Saying that we are
all Christ, that we all have Christ
within us. If we just unlock that
gnostic spark and we will reach a higher
plane of existence, we will become a
higher evolved spiritual being. Which is
exactly what Lucifer's argument, the the
start of rebellion in heaven was about
Lucifer wanting to be like God. He
looked at God and he said, "How come I'm
not like you? I will ascend my throne to
the heights of the clouds. I will be
like the most high." That's what
spiritual transcendence means, to be
like God. Do you remember we did a
video? Check it out. Look under our live
tabs. You'll see where Trump got
inaugurated and he was inside of the DC
capital instead of outside like it
normally happens. And it happened right
under this dome with a painting of
George Washington up in the clouds with
angels. And the name of this painting,
this mural on the ceiling, Washington's
apotheiois, which means to to make one a
god. And Trump got inaugurated in there.
So Trump's getting inaugurated under the
apotheiois
mural, telling everyone we're entering
into the golden age. We just happened to
turn lead into gold, which is the
alchemist dream. Trump's saying that
we're going to be uh governed by AI,
that we're entering into a singularity
movement. This is the year that just
passed was the year of the
externalization of the hierarchy
according to Alice Bailey. And now we
have this new year display of the
phoenix rising from the ashes. And it's
not just this display. We're going to
look at more stuff. So this is what this
is. It's not just some Christian
experience of getting a closer walk with
God. This is becoming God. Now, the
Lucius Trust, the modern front for the
Theosophy, originally named Lucifer
Publishing Company in 1922. It was later
renamed Lucious Trust for PR reasons.
The key facts here are that it was
founded by Allison Foster Bailey,
Disciples of Bllovzky. It publishes
books by Alice Bailey who also claimed
to receive telepathic transmissions from
an ascended master named Jakool.
And it promotes new age doctrines,
planetary initiation, externalization of
the hierarchy, and world governance by
enlightened beings. All right, this
stuff was written in 1922. Like in the
early 1900s,
Alice Bailey was getting these chneled
writings saying that we are going to be
governed by enlightened beings. All
right, the externalization of the
hierarchy. This is already happening.
For anyone that's like, well, where is
it happening? I haven't seen it yet.
Just watch the news when they say, oh,
they have the military and uh US
congressional hearings saying, oh yeah,
we we see alien craft every day. We
don't know what they are. We we
communicate with nonhuman intelligences.
Well, are they alien? We don't know.
They're they could be interdimensional
beings. This is what the militaries of
the world, our governments of the world
are telling us. We communicate with
interdimensional beings. All right? So,
this is the externalization of the
hierarchy. It's here, guys. Like, 2026
is about to get nuts. I I don't know if
everyone understands this. I think it's
like the days of Noah where we're just
eating and drinking and giving in
marriage and it's life as usual. But we
are about to enter some crazy times.
They're telling us AI is going to take
all your jobs. We were just in
California for a wedding and I saw
numerous five or six self-driving cars
that were Ubers.
I've been saying this for months that AI
is going to take over so many different
jobs. And I would throw in Uber in
there. Even though I never seen a
self-driving car as an Uber, now they
have them. There's no one in the front
seat. You climb in the back and the car
takes you there. So, think about all the
jobs that are going to be lost. Voice
over, narration, writers, artist, Uber
drivers. All these jobs are going to be
gone at one time. And what's going to
happen? Elon Musk said we have to come
up with a universal basic income, a
social credit system. We're about to
enter an age, the golden age, where we
can all have everything. We're all
wealthy, but in order to have that
wealth, you must obey the rules of the
tyrannical dystopian world where you
have to go to the universal church, the
coexist church, the the church of
tolerance and acceptance. That was
another thing we saw in California that
was crazy. We didn't go there, but there
was a sign on the interstate, like not a
billboard that was paid for, a
governmentissued metal sign on the side
of the interstate that said Museum of
Tolerance.
And and the interstate was created by uh
United Atheist United. I mean, it's it's
a different world out there. We felt
spiritual darkness while we were in LA
driving through it. There was nothing
redemptive at all there. There wasn't a
Christian church. There might have been
some weird churches there, but it was
just like sex over here, drugs over
here, the most wicked movies, whatever.
Everything was wicked in LA. It's crazy.
I haven't been there in a while, so it
was kind of shell shock. And so, where
did these channeled writings come from?
We read it was Jahool, right? And who is
that? He's a Tibetan master. Jakul, a
revered spiritual teacher in
theosophical and esoteric traditions,
believed to be an ascended master or
Mahhat Mahatma who telepathically
transmitted vast teachings on ageless
wisdom to Alice A. Bailey between 1919
and 1949.
So, she was getting these channeled
writings from an ascended master, from a
spiritual being that is not a holy
angel. It's not God. These are fallen
angels communicating with her. And she
wrote these books and they made it into
the United Nations. We're about to get
into that. He channeled extensive
teachings to her leading to the founding
of the Arcane School and the Lucius
Trust, formerly Lucifer Publishing
Company. Now, how does this connect to
the UN? Well, this is the official
Lucius Trust website, and this is
talking about goodwill is love in
action. Notice what it says right there.
Do you see this?
Phoenix Rising, the Rebirth of
Civilization.
This was a channelneled writing by Alice
Bailey talking about the Phoenix Rising
and the rebirth of a civilization.
Our rebirth, the whole civilization is
going to be reborn. Okay? And when you
read on, it it says, "The process
whereby civilization periodically
remakes itself can be profoundly
unsettling for those who live through
it." That's us. Okay. This is especially
true now as the process accelerates.
Moreover, people now live longer and may
expect to see many more changes in their
life uh in their life than previous
generations. So, as the many changes
accumulate, they may even come to feel
that the civilization they were born
into is dying. I already feel like that.
and and being replaced by something
quite alien. Dude, this is crazy
language right here. Okay, it's saying
because of our longer lifespans than
maybe the 20s or something or 1700s,
whatever, we're actually seeing the our
civilization, our generation or
whatever, be completely replaced by
something quite alien. Alice Bailey
remarked
on this when she noted that dying
civilizations are present in their final
forms whilst new civilizations are
emerging. Cycles come and go and in the
going overlap. You're catching this
right? Like this is where we're at.
We're being told from all sides. I mean
this this thing that happened wasn't
even in America. We got Trump in America
talking about this stuff. We got this
ritual going on over here that was seen
by tens of thousands of people. It was
televised. It uh broke a Guinness book
world record.
This is purposeful. This isn't just for
show. Okay. Now, check out the next line
here. One of the most ancient world
symbols is the phoenix, the great bird,
which is periodically consumed through
fire and then reborn. In the ageless
wisdom, fire is often used to symbolize
the mind. As we know, fire can be both
beneficient and destructive.
It is up to all people of goodwill to
learn the work constructively with the
mind, taking our place somewhere within
the many groups which compose the new
group of world servers. I just when I
hear this, I'm thinking new world order
all the way. The new group of world
servers seeking to contact the high
vision of a future world where the good
of the whole informs every organ of
society. Then the phoenix of
civilization can be safely reborn and s
soar to greater heights.
I know this sounds lovely
when you hear good will and love and
we're going to our whole civilization is
about to be morphed and changed into
this loving state of humanity. It's not
true. When you read all these writings,
you're going to find out what that
means. I don't have it all in here, but
just look up what
uh what was the idea of this age of
Aquarius, this new shift, the golden
age, all that stuff. It was about a a
world where everyone's on a different
spiritual plane and we're all united in
spirituality.
And it's really it's really weird stuff.
You got to look into it. So here is the
official website of the UN and look
right here it says Lucius Trust
Association Lucius Trust. So they are
holding hands somehow the United Nations
and Lucius Trust which was all these
channeled writings by Alice Bailey.
And so I looked up uh this meditation
room that I'd heard about. Yes, the
United Nations in the New York in New
York has a famous meditation room also
called a room of quiet located in the
general assembly building designed by
former secretary general Dag I can't say
that word. Amar scold
featuring a large iron ore altar
from Sweden and an abstract mural by
Boescow
intended as a universal space for
stillness, reflection, and inner peace
for people of all faiths according to
the UN sources. Okay. So, there this
room has an altar. And I don't think
that it was just Hm. What would be a
nice piece of furniture in here? There's
no chairs. We'll put a a big slab of
iron ore. I don't think it was just
pulled out of a hat. I think this was
directed in some way, inspired by some
kind of spirit in some way. And here it
is right here on the United Nations
website. You can look this up, the
meditation room on the United Nations
website. And uh I asked, "Was the United
Nations meditation room inspired in any
way by Alice Bailey or Lucius Trust?"
And it says, "The United Nations
meditation room was personally planned
and supervised in every detail by the
second UN Secretary General Dag and was
not directly designed by Alice Bailey or
Lucius Trust. However, sources from
Lucius Trust and related critical
analysis indicate that the room's
philosophy aligns with certain new age
concepts supported by Lucius Trust and
the organization has a historical
association with the UN. So even though
it was not Alice Bailey that directed
these people on how to build this
meditation room, the same spirit was
directing this DAG guy because she's got
this channelneled writings going on.
He's making this uh meditation room and
somehow they are identical.
And it says Dag's vision was a deeply
spiritual he was a a deeply spiritual
yet private man. wanted a
non-denominational space where people of
all faiths could find stillness and
interest.
His vision for the room was, and you can
read a link, but here's where it says
connection to, this is from Google,
guys, connection to Alice Bailey and
Lucius Trust. And it says shared
concepts. Lucius Trust Publications view
the UN as an outer vehicle for a
spiritual plan. What?
Lucius Trust Publications view the UN as
an outer vehicle for a spiritual plan
and see the imagery in the meditation
room like a stream of energy in the
golden background. Here we go with the
gold again as aligned with their
esoteric philosophy.
NGO status. Lucius Trust and its
associated initiative world goodwill
have held non-governmental organization
uh con consultive status with the UN
economic and social council. Uh let's
skip on maintenance. Some sources state
that the UN meditation room is
maintained by the Lucius Trust. Very
interesting philosophical influence.
Critics suggest that the
interdenominational universalist
approach of the room aligns with the new
age concept promoted by Bailey which
focus on a coming world teacher and a
unified global spiritual order. This is
what I'm talking about. This is what all
this is leading to. This is what the
externalization of the hierarchy is
about. This is what the golden age is
about. This is what alchemy is about.
This is what uh the phoenix rising from
the ashes, the oraorus, all this is
about.
We are about to meet our one world
spiritual teacher. Who is that? Who's
who's the one world spiritual teacher
that's coming? None other than Satan
coming as Christ doing lying signs and
wonders, performing miracle, miracle
working demons. The book of Revelation
says millions of people, including
Christians, are going to be deceived by
this major deception because they're
they don't understand how prophecy
works, the timing of it, is there
pre-trip rapture? Is there not? Is there
uh is Jesus going to set foot on the
ground? Is he not? Is the millennium
earthly kingdom going to be on earth or
is it in heaven? All these questions
because people aren't studying the word
of God. They're not understanding
prophecy. That's why it's so important
to have the testimony of Jesus Christ
and the spirit of prophecy to have the
the testimony of Jesus Christ that we
can be transformed and have a a life
changed by God and we can share what
Jesus Christ has done in our life but
also the spirit of prophecy
understanding prophetic events so that
we will not be deceived in these last
days. Being deceived by this final
deception is a salvation issue. If you
fall for the one world church to come,
that is the mark of the beast. If you
take the mark of the beast, you are
damned. You will partake in the plagues,
and you will not be
you will not enter into the kingdom of
heaven. So, it is super important to
understand prophetic events, what's
happening, what's coming, and how to not
be deceived by it. And that's mine and
my wife's prayer daily is Lord, give us
eyes of discernment. help us to see
through the deceptions of this world.
They're coming from all angles. And I
know the deception is going to be so
great. When you see a spiritual being in
person, like an angel of light doing
signs and wonders and miracles, how are
we going to deny that unless we stand on
the word of God and deny our senses,
deny what we see, deny our emotions,
deny everything except the prophetic
word of God. That's the only way we
cannot be deceived in these last days
for what's coming.
Lucius trust promotes a one world
religion, one world government,
initiation into Christ consciousness,
purification by fire, often symbolic,
sometimes literal. This is the phoenix
doctrine. Death of the old age, rise of
the new age or the old world into the
new world order.
And I asked, "Does the book of morals
and dogma reference the phoenix rising
from the ashes at all?" And it says,
'Yes. Albert Pike, morals and dogma. If
you don't know who he is, Albert Pike is
a very high esteemed Freemason. And he
wrote this very thick book called Morals
and Dogma. And in there, he says, "We
worship Lucifer." That's what he says in
the book. The book discusses the phoenix
as a quintessential
symbol in alchemy again with alchemy and
the western mystery tradition parallel
to other resurrection myths myths
specifically the text mentions the
phoenix as a symbol of regeneration of
universal life and the successful
completion of an alchemical process. We
just saw that we literally discovered
alchemy this year. Or at least it was
introduced to us this year. The
mythological bird consumed by fire only
to rise again from its own ashes came to
be adopted in early Christian thought as
a symbol of the resurrection. I don't
believe that at all. This is talking
about Catholicism. Don't believe this.
The idea that humanity, much like the
phoenix, destroys itself in fire, but
can start again from the ashes. a
concept related to learning from past
tragedies. One specific Masonic source
notes that an early grandmaster of the
Templars after Jacqu de Mole Almont is
said to have used a seal of the phoenix
brooding on the flames with the motto
she burns that she may live which ties
the symbolism directly into Masonic
thought and history.
Pike incorporates a wide array of
ancient religious and philosophical
concepts and morals and dogma using them
as allegorories to explain the moral and
philosophical teachings of the Scottish
right rather than as literal doctrine.
So
the reason I the reason this is
intriguing to me is because our world is
run by Freemasons. I believe there's
people above them. But our government,
you go into any city, you drive into any
city, I don't care how small it is,
there is a big sign out there that shows
the Freemasons, the Order of the Eastern
Star, the Lions Club, and they're
saying, "Welcome to our city that's run
by these secret societies."
So this guy who wrote morals and dogma
about philosophies and all this stuff is
talking about the phoenix rising from
the ashes. And
here's actually lodges. There's a whole
order of these masons that are called
the phoenix lodge.
Observing self to manifest change that
evolves reality. Notice there's a
cushion on the floor of this checkered
floor. You're supposed to kneel before
somebody right here. I I've had people
that I personally know try to defend
the Freemasons and say, "Oh, it's just a
club. It's nothing religious about it."
And I go to his house and there's a
plaque of him right there with all these
brothers around him. He's wearing an
apron. It's got a gavvel sitting on the
plaque and it says, "Uh, worshipful
master." I'm like, how are you going to
say how are you going to say worshipful
master is not about religion? It's it's
insane the level of deception that these
people are in. And here's the logo,
Phoenix Lodge. And you see this Egyptian
Phoenix with the sun over its head.
Here is a a clock that was carved in 18
in the 1870s
by a Freemason. It's got the Masonic
compass on there. And and I found this
on an official Mason website as I was
looking up Phoenix Rising from the ashes
and the Freemasons. And so I'm just
showing you connections here. The
connections are that this Phoenix rising
from the ashes that they openly admitted
to us at the New Year party.
They said it was a phoenix rising from
the ashes. Okay? It wasn't just a bird.
And I was saying, "Oh, that kind of
looks like a phoenix." They said it.
It's a cult. It's alchemical. It's
freemasonic. It's gnostic. And it's all
ushering in the new world order and the
externalization of the hierarchy.
I believe this is the year 2026. I
believe this is the year. I'm not a
prophet. I just have a gut feeling that
this is the year that the governments of
the world are going to say, "We can't
hide it any longer. Aliens are here.
They're living among us. They've already
been here for thousands of years and you
didn't even know it." You know why?
because they're peaceful and they've
been helping us and they've even created
some of our technology. They're some of
our greatest scientists or something,
you know, and they're going to say
they're here to help us. They're here to
help us because there is an evil alien
invader coming.
And if we don't side with these beings,
we are not going to survive.
And Revelation says that three unclean
spirits like frogs are going to unite
the militaries of the world together to
fight against the second coming of
Christ. And I believe we are there. I
believe this is like the next thing to
happen in prophecy. Satan appearing
manifesting as this cosmic Christ that
can do all these miracles. That's going
to happen. Like I said, I'm not a
prophet. That's a harder thing to say
100% like that's going to happen this
year. But 2026, I believe, is going to
be full disclosure. There's been soft
disclosure for like five, six years now,
telling us, "Yeah, we see stuff. Yeah,
we communicate with things. We don't
know what they are." But I believe this
is the year. And I and all this esoteric
stuff, rituals
are making me all the more believe it.
We had a movie called Avatar come out or
is about to come out called Fire and
Ash. I was like, "Interesting." with the
one eye symbolism. Of course, the the A
logo looks like a Masonic compass and it
is a phoenix rising right out of the
glowing fire. And I asked, does the new
Avatar movie Fire and Ash have any
reference to the Phoenix rising from the
ashes? Yes, the movie Avatar Fire and
Ash directly references the concept of
the phoenix rising from the ashes in
both its themes and specific project
names within the film. So there's a
project Phoenix in the movie project
Phoenix
and and the whole the whole theme of it
is about rising out of the ashes. the
thematic significance. James Cameron has
explained that the subtitle fire and ash
represents a cycle of violence, hatred,
which is fire, grief, and loss, which is
ash. He stated, "From the ashes of war,
a new fire will rise." The narrative
explores the idea of rebuilding, we've
heard that term, and new beginnings
after destruction, which ties closely to
the phoenix symbolism of rebirth.
If you guys have not checked out our
videos from the past, go to our live
section, scroll back to where you see uh
the lasers, the lasers that happened in
California and Hawaii where these cities
were completely vaporized.
Houses are turned to ash. There's
nothing left. Not a refrigerator, not a
washing machine, not a chimney. It's
complete ash. And yet all around it is
green plant life that was unaffected by
these supposed wildfires. And what
happened? What happens to these places
is they rebuild it with a smart city.
They destroy the old and bring in the
new. The tyrannical dystopian smart city
that's allseeing AI governed all that.
This has already been happening. We had
an incident happen with turning point.
We had a turning point. I think that's
an interesting name. We had a turning
point. We're about to be at a turning
point. And where is the turning point
headquarters? None other than Phoenix
in Phoenix, Arizona.
And when Erica Kirk got on live
television and spoke to the masses, she
said, "You have no idea the fire that
has been ignited.
the phoenix, the fire,
and then they changed their logo from
this 180 degree or yeah, a a 180 degree
turn to a 360° turn. That does not make
sense. Turning point used to be this
logo right here because you're you're
going in one direction, but you're going
to turn around the other direction.
That's a a positive thing. When you're
on the wrong path, you need to turn
around. But now they have this new logo.
It's a 360, which just means you're
spinning around in circles and
who knows which way you're going, but
it's none other than the Oraoris logo.
And what is the Oraoris? It's the same
thing as the phoenix rising from the
ashes. It's this whole occult alchemal
gnostic symbol
that means we are about to enter into a
big shift, guys. something big is
coming.
They're telling us Trump is saying I'm
Well, Trump already did it. November
24th or something like that was when he
initiated the Genesis mission. And I
asked, "Will Genesis mission bring us
into singularity?" And AI's answer,
Google's answer was, "Well, it's not
supposed to. That's not what the object
is,
but it's probably going to be the start
of it that we're about to enter into a
singularity movement. Digital IDs,
uh, Genesis mission,
Stargate, AI surveillance, smart cities,
smart everything. This is the age we're
entering into.
They're telling us aliens are coming. We
We communicate with non-human
intelligences. We don't know what they
are. This is where we're at, guys. This
is crazy times. All right. Now, Alice
Bailey's book, they're all still
published by Lucius Trust, repeatedly
reference these things. A need for
destruction and purging.
Fire as a spiritual force of rebirth,
the appearance of a coming one, a
messiah, a messianic world teacher who
will unite all faiths. We already saw
this with Pope Francis. He was saying
all religions are like different
languages to God. They're all valid. We
all worship the same God. We just got
different ways of communicating that.
It's not true. There's one way to God.
Jesus is the only way.
Initiation into the new age through
trials, fire, and surrender of self. So,
here's some final takeaways. Esoteric
texts that directly link Phoenix to the
new age and the new man. Theosophy and
Lucius Trust still United affiliated
with the United Nations
uh UN affiliated with the United Nations
officially but historically linked teach
a coming age of enlightened humanity.
Use fire, light, rebirth and initiation.
The Phoenix archetype appears
repeatedly.
Transhumanist writings from 2019 to 2025
say that humanity must die to be reborn.
Carbon is obsolete. Death is a bug to be
fixed. Man is trying to figure out how
to become immortal through technology.
Anything but God. They want to achieve
eternal life through anything but
Christ. Can we do it through AI? Can we
do it through this and that? Can we do
it through meditation?
You know why?
Because man, we we have a sinful desire.
We are fallen being and we gravitate
towards wicked things. And the number
one reason why most people don't
surrender their lives to God are because
of two things.
Sex and mind alteration.
That's what it they want to fornicate in
every way possible and they want to do
anything to alter their mind. And these
are two things that God doesn't want us
to do. Not because he wants to take away
our fun, but because these things lead
to death and destruction. Look at
somebody who's been drinking for 40
years. How is their health? Look at
somebody who's been doing drugs for 20,
30, 40 years. Look at somebody who's
been having sex with as many people in
as many ways with as many different
varieties of people as they want and see
where their health is. STDs, brain
damage, abortions,
all these things is where that road
leads. And yet these are the reasons why
so many people forfeit eternal life.
Look at Demi Lovado. She openly says she
got baptized in the Jordan River and a
year later she was denouncing her faith
and making an album in opposition to God
because she wanted to be a lesbian or
pansexual or whatever. Then you got
Miley Cyrus, same thing. All these
celebrities are saying, "I don't want
God because I want to have sex any way I
want to and I want to intoxicate my
mind. I want to kill myself slowly and
destroy my brain." World Economic Forum
language. We've been hearing the great
reset, re-imagine, rebuild, build back
better, right? And the fourth industrial
revolution.
That's AI. That's transhumanism. That's
we're being governed by robots and
computers.
And none of this is used in Christian
language. This is all about self-s
salvation, alchemy.
what 2026 symbolizes. Why why is this
the time 2026 is being framed as a a
post-pandemic world? Full AI integration
phase. Digital IDs are being normalized.
Biotech neural interface expansion. This
is what the Genesis mission is all
about. And the Phoenix signals
the old world is gone and the new man
has arrived. That's what this was all
about. That's what this phoenix rising
from the ashes, morphing into a digital
man was all about. It was a religious
ritual ceremony signaling to the whole
world that we are entering the phase of
singularity of transhumanism
of the world is being governed by
computers by AI total surveillance
state. This is where we're at, guys. I I
hate to not have like a hopeful message
for the first of January of first day of
2026,
but we are called to be the watchmen.
We're called to expose Satan's
deceptions. And I see a lost, blind
world out there who has no idea what's
coming around the corner. And this is
going to take them like an overwhelming
surprise. Be ready, guys. Choose ye this
day whom you will serve. Today is the
day of salvation. Choose today to pray
more, to read God's word more, to study
more, to really don't just read it, but
study it line upon line, precept upon
precept. Find out what what is about to
happen in prophecy so that you won't be
deceived. Because what's coming is like
nothing this world has ever experienced.